yeah I think animal rights is the next
wave after the same-sex marriage we just
got done with that and that'll be pretty
much over in terms of social attitudes
within a few years to a decade no one
will even talk about it anymore
what's next animal rights and that also
I think you know you don't want to say
environmental rights but the rights of
future generations to have a live a
sustainable earth of planet to live on I
think we do owe an obligation moral
obligation future generations and
animals for a balanced ecosystem and I
think we'll get there I think we're on
our way there but in terms of animal
rights where do we start we start where
Jeremy Bentham really the founding
father of animal rights and rights in
general natural rights concept is that
it's not can they talk or reason can
they suffer so it began in case of
animals because they can't tell us I
want the right to vote or what we're not
talking about that can they live a life
without suffering that that we have
improved you know the all the laws
against animal cruelty dogfighting bear
baiting you know cat nailing to the post
and all the cruel things people used to
do to animals we've we've largely gotten
over that both ideas on the way out you
know cockfighting is illegal in most
countries and so the next step then I
think I'm on board with Temple Grandin
that is the modification of the you know
meat industry so that cattle or not they
don't suffer as much I think we need to
get away of in the long run from factory
farms it's not healthy anyway the food
is not good for you it really isn't
you're really better off eating organic
foods foods that are you know grown or
raised on small farms the EU is really
good about this like the chicken cages
can't be too small and you know the cows
have to be free to walk around and and
you know I'm still concerned about like
taking the calf away from the female
cows because that's how they get them to
generate more milk and any of this not
good for those they don't like it they
scream and cry and those are kind of
things that we're making a lot of
progress on have a ways to go in the
long run you know century or two maybe
we'll have synthetic meat I kind of see
that you know the Google guys are
working on that problem I think that's
just a
it's just a molecular machinery problem
and so I think we can get there in time
that one's gonna happen slower than
same-sex marriage women's rights civil
rights simply because it's a these are
different species that we care less
about them but as the moral sphere
continues to expand you know we've
already banned the use of chimpanzees
and medical research as of this year
that's it they're all being retired and
they go to Club Med for chimps great
how about monkeys let's let's to keep
the figure out a little bit more all
marine mammals whales dolphins cetaceans
and so on and just keep going it'll take
a while decades you know but we're
getting there yeah I think the idea of
being a carnivore we'll look back on
that as like we look back at the Romans
you know it's a how barbaric of them
it's totally understandable why we made
I love DP you know and I'm not there I'm
not quite vegetarian vegan you know I'm
what's called a reduce it Arian there's
an actual group the reduce at Aryans
reduce your meat-eating okay hey it's a
goal and the reason for that that I like
is because it's practical because you
know if you go okay I'm going vegan
that's it I'm not gonna eat another
piece of man then you have a steak you
know oh no I feel so bad I've sinned I
have to go confess my sins and you know
it's practically like a religion and I
don't like that so let's just see if we
can reduce the factory farm carnage just
eat less meat and if you're gonna eat
meat no meatless Mondays or what how
about just meat Mondays and no other
meat for the week and if he eat meat
then just eat the you know the fact not
that the factory farm meat but the
organic me that came from a small farm
increments I call this proto Pia instead
of aiming for utopia where everything's
perfect forever and we're all just
sinless okay forget that that's not
going to happen just see if we can make
today slightly better than yesterday and
tomorrow slightly better than today just
incrementally proto Pia
you